Shin fin will be the largest party of
government in Northern Ireland for the
first time ever as they were the largest
party at Stormwind in last year's
Assembly Election what does that mean
for the Democratic unionists with us to
discuss that is the party leader Sir
Jeffrey Donaldson thank you for joining
us not the result that eup would have
hoped for
well I think David if you actually look
at the real results and not the spin
that some commentators are trying to put
on it the dup has increased its share of
the vote from last year and we're on
Coast to win a lot of seats across all
the councils are going down we've made
gains in a number of countries of course
they won't be reported by the media
because it doesn't suit The Narrative
that says
but I'm not going to accept that the dup
has pulled strongly in this election
despite everything that's been thrown at
us despite the challenges we have faced
the dup is doing well our vote is held
up well we've increased our we certainly
shared the vote from last year we're
winning six in pencils were winning six
of this is our number one seats before
so why has Sinn Fein become the largest
party of local government in Northern
Ireland I think there are a number of
reasons for that of all the collapse of
the sdlp again being ignored by many
commentators and you're seeing that
right across countries in Northern
Ireland secondly there is a differential
in Union must have to accept this there
is a differential in turnout in areas
where shin-free and do better than in
areas where Union must be better and we
need to look as unionist contents of why
not enough of our people are turning out
to vote particularly in time to learn so
Jeffrey you asked unionists to come out
and strengthen your hand in negotiations
with Rishi sunak in protest at
post-brexit trading Arrangements but
they haven't done that the turnout was
low in unionist constituencies what does
that say if they're sitting at home well
actually David that's wrong again they
turn out in unionist areas is where it
was at the last Council of election so
let's get our facts right here but there
is a deferential that has been
consistently a differential between
further unionist areas and
to ensure that our place in the United
Kingdom is not only respected but is
protected in law and I believe the
Mandate we've been given in this and
actually reinforces about this so what
does it mean for the big picture are you
telling us that you are not for moving
on your position of boycotting the power
sharing government at stormonts no I'm
saying what I said to the electors I've
got a mandate for which is vote for us
to finish the job and what is that it is
to secure an organizers in the United
Kingdom which is the will of the
majority of people in Northern Ireland
it is to remove the barriers to create
between Northern and Great Britain and
to ensure in law that our ability to
train for the rest of the UK is
protected I believe that can happen
quickly the government can move almost
when they do that we will step up we
will see storm at the store and on a
more stable foundation and that is
important just one final question given
the results of this election is it not
clear that people have greater concerns
around the cost of living and the budget
crisis at Stormont than they do around
the Constitutional questions of whether
Northern Ireland should remain part of
the UK or be part of the United Ireland
well you can't separate
the jeopard issue Northern being part of
the UK is fundamentally important for
our economy for Prosperity here and our
Health Service that the welfare support
that people receive these things are
important part of what the United
Kingdom is and of course we want to be
tackling the issues of modern people who
are doing that on the ground we want to
see stronger back up and running but
we've also got to tackle the big problem
which is that the trade was our biggest
Market is impacted by the protocol
that's harming our economy and we need
that effects